[Music]
20 international chess professionals
converged in st. Louis for the 2017 fall
chess classic round six of the Fall
Classic here in st. Louis had a little
bit of everything from the surprising
ease of a victory to the heartbreaking
defeat in a big upset these players all
lie outside the world top 50 which means
that they are more apt to take risks to
maybe play a bluff on the board and it
reflects because in both groups a and B
today there were three decisive games
the fields combined have a prize fund of
$36,000 the top prize in Group A is 6
grand the top prize in Group B is 4
grand we play one classical round of
chess every day through Thursday
September 14 rounds begin at 1:00 p.m.
here in st. Louis except for the last
day which begins earlier it was a very
important victory today for Grandmaster
Georg Meier in Group A taking on another
one of the leaders in a big game in this
in the standings race here against
Kovalev garrett give us your thoughts on
this game today actually I played them
last year with the white pieces at the
Olympiad where he was representing
Belarus and I was playing for Germany
and already back then I had kind of made
up my mind how I should play against him
and I actually beat him quite easily
back then too so when I showed the gamer
I can tell a bit more about my general
game plan but it pretty much worked well
again well let's have a look at it yes
oh now this I play basically everything
but right not only Knight f3 I also play
d4 on the first move
and my last white game I played before
here against him enough and sometimes I
even play c4
so basically when I'm white I try to
find the opening that I think will be
most uncomfortable for my opponent and
Koval if is a very good Kings Indian
player and although I have a very good
score against the Kings Indian I always
felt that positions after I mean this
this slow buildup less shooting his
style and more mind because they're
usually quite symmetrical and there was
not much counter play so he played c5 I
wasn't sure what you would do here he
can of course just castle which is the
normal line and then either played d6 or
d5 anyway so he played c5 c4 and here is
an interesting moment he could try to do
almost the same as in the game like this
and here it's not possible for white to
play d4 because black has already
overprotected d4 too many times and can
just retreat the Queen and I cannot
recuperate upon so it may be the knight
c6 is actually more accurate way to play
for black so he played castles and
that's a 3d 5 and here we have two
different to take him play d4 at once
and of course being white with the
naturally tan development it's nice for
me to open the position if I can
so here the point is Bishop e3 and white
will wind upon on d4 BEC because this is
going to be quite unpleasant that Bishop
g2 hitting the Queen on d5 so he played
differing that I will destroy my pawn
structure or kind of weaken it by taking
on different
Queen upon but White has this neat
maneuver 91 hitting the Queen and
rerouting the knight to a very good
square d free and keeping my pawn
structure intact and of course it's nice
that the bishops on g2 and III and our
free and active so normal development
and yeah I was thinking for a long time
because before seems very obvious just
using again melittin development trying
to play concretely before black finishes
his development and the point is that
night before us I think very bad here we
would get into a position where all of
whites piece is extremely active and I
were probably quite easily when the
whole black Queen side but what I was
thinking about all the time was the move
Queen f3 and I think cover left didn't
give it enough thought so the point is
that after Queen see one Queen a4 it
looks at first very bad from neck
because you should not take on before
then on the next move I take on b7 and
there's havoc on the long diagonal but
what's quite annoying as Queen b5
hitting e 2 and a 1 and well after move
like f4 Queen e2 like I saw always ready
to play Knight d4 and he has taken a
very important on only two so I was not
exactly sure what I would play I thought
probably I should go for something like
this
and just hope that black is not in time
to exchange his weaknesses and that I
can get a grip on the position with a
better construction instead of all this
he played quindi had quite quickly which
i think is just a mistake I mean he goes
back with the Queen were actually the
rook should soon go sir rooks you wanna
know he was thinking for a long time the
most natural would be 94 because of
course I've threatened to just take on
g6 and I thought that black has great
difficulties to basically and untangle
in this position since well b7 is
hanging and if you play this then you
might not manage to develop the pieces
at all actually c6 is threatening to win
immediately and otherwise I just wanna
win the pennant on b7 so I think 94
would be correct and he would have to
find something else here for instance
you can play would be 8 but then after
Queen move yes trouble finding a good
spot for the for his own Queen so it's
the worst position for black but should
still be playable instead he went Ruby
hit and surprisingly I think the
position is has a lot of details I
wanted that first to just play Queen d2
rock fd1 finish development and increase
the pressure but here it turns out that
you can play Knight d4 and I cannot play
the natural Bishop f4 because my queen
will be hanging on the turn
and if I do something slower like rook
fd1 he will play Bishop g4 annoying me
on it too
and he'll just take back with the Queen
and he's ready to play b6 so just take
away the target on b7 anytime soon and
it's quite close to equal I think so I
played f4 my point is simply that done
Knight d4 I have two very strong Bishop
f4 if I feel lose opponent of course
playing okay it is very sad because I
get to go to c7 and just kick out the
nitro different or e3 right away
circulate a6 you know he allows me to
fix this whole Queen side with a 5 and
the pawn on b7 of course can be weak
forever also he played the s6 because in
this position I cannot really take this
pawn he's taking back on his own so one
point of f4 was simply to have the pawn
protected by the Queen so I'm
threatening to take on c6 and a 7 so we
got here and now I thought I'm much
better and probably thought so too does
without much thinking he play d5 but now
he has great problems of coordination
I'm actually not sure what what he can
play here because Bishop c5 is quite
annoying when he plays something like
this so he played Queen f6 and now is
basically completely collapsing after
Bishop c7 since I had to rock on b8 pawn
on e5 and yeah I'm basically already
winning so what followed is just
desperation Bishop g4 and here I have a
choice I mean everything is winning for
me but I try to get to a position that
is easy to play of course I can take on
b8 but I decided to just take this
Bishop on g7 and have a superior
structure extra pawn strong Knights
against miss plays Bishop on Jefferson
that's in
for a technical win so basically here
not much is going on and yeah slowly but
surely I should convert easily and here
I actually managed to blend a very soon
he played King at seven and initially my
idea with roopd six was to just play a
four which is winning and okay I guess
he would have done something like this
and well just playing hoping the devil
be some chick in the position but it's
already two points up and well I
wouldn't take only six because then he
gets some counter play against making
but
well what I did was simply a blunder but
it turns out that I'm probably winning
anyways so I wanted to play he forward
even more comfort just play Roxy v next
or H for I have a lot of strengthening
moves and he actually has no idea unless
I blended like edits in the game so this
is his point he takes on c1 since I was
a long time he was cheeky enough to
offer draw here but I started after you
for actually he's just collapsing since
if he goes back I'm just meeting and
there was nothing yet or perpetual so
he's played c5
Quinn be seven and ya know yeah I saw
some nice way to finish the game so
everything is hanging FFC eight of seven
he played King J it took on a five okay
it and now this I saw an advanced it
here I will finished again with this new
trick and there was no defense against
mate on g7 that draw offer that he made
do you find something like that
offensive or not she didn't have time
himself to evaluate the position at this
point because I blended into this trick
and since I was low on time I guess it
was just you know psychologically smart
move it was not that clear that she
would be lost but of course I think he
understood he has to be worse but I mean
there are cases when someone offers to
draw and he's lost and enough I mean
when it's clear to both that of course
is not appropriate I mean especially
your guys level this tournament designed
for the 2400 to 2600 range these
invitationals are kind of rare around
here how often do you get invited to a
tournament like this and what are your
thoughts on the format actually I think
no it's it's the best time to be playing
for the US as a youngster because this
is exactly what you need to improve if
you are someone like I wonder young or
young or any of
the young promising talents the USS you
need these round robins again strong
competition because every game is
basically a training it's a lesson and
you grow while if you just play some
open then most of the time when you are
GM already you go play weak opposition
and the objective is just to win some
prize money and not really to improve
your chess
well this is the right setting so to
actually make make progress as a chess
player and most other countries actually
no country has what you do not with a
set of round-robin tournaments every
single season four times a year so I
think that's that's a fantastic idea
that to just practice implementing and
it really is exciting to think about who
may emerge from these fields that we're
having you know every three months or so
we have one of these tournaments and and
some of them there are some norm
situations as well in them so that's
another angle
and right now you sit atop Group A so
that's very exciting stuff Georg thank
you for joining me I do appreciate it
and a good luck down the stretch in the
final rounds let's take a look at the
rest of the standings for group a after
six rounds have been played Meier has
got to be happy lifetime score two and O
against Vladislav Kovalev and Myers
still sits atop the ranks with yaro zero
book can he hold that top spot until the
end of Thursday that's the day of the
final round remember there will be a
playoff if there is a tied top score at
the end of this thing only one can be
the champion the most important game in
Group A for Tuesday September 12th is
yaro versus daro the Battle of the
slough students on board number two
Group B saw a true shocker today as Tata
of Avraham Ian defeated her good friend
Alejandra Ramirez who was strongly
favored to win and Alejandro is at the
top of the tournament he gave away the
full point to Tata Tata blasted him off
the board both players were emotionally
kind of upset afterward as they are very
good friends this was a big loss for
Alejandro and Tata have had trouble
finding
enjoying the victory out of concern for
her friend it really is lose-lose
sometimes when you play someone with
whom you are so close on Tuesday
September 12 alejandro tries to dust
himself off he has the white pieces
against Josh Reidel that game along with
Pavley DS and Pichu are the games to
watch in Group B big standings on the
line there
each rounds notable players will be
interviewed in this recap but remember
to follow the games live every day at
1:00 p.m. in st. Louis via chess 24 and
us chess champs dot-com